a family film that is not CGI or 3d the
buffets we all know the Muppets who
doesn't like the Muppets probably
somebody doesn't like the Muppets I grew
up in the Muppet Show I watched the
Muppet movies when I was a kid I have
always been a fan of them and the really
cool thing about the show was that it
wasn't just for kids it was something
the whole family could watch and
everyone could enjoy it had jokes for
everyone and it was legitimately funny
it was very funny it was a great show
and the movies were good too you sent
from a big trip to LA there's somebody
coming excuse me good grief Jason Segel
and the Addams and Little Walter decided
to go find the Muppets and get them all
back together so they can do one last
show to hopefully raise enough money to
buy back Muppet Studios I enjoyed this
movie it was very fun very similar to
the show how it was just lots of clever
humor for the whole family there were a
lot of musical numbers and as I've said
before generally I'm not a huge fan of
musical numbers and movies but here it
worked really well I thought they were
catchy songs were good and there was a
message behind the songs but one of the
things I really liked about the musical
numbers was that they joked about it in
film it was a part where a character was
like what do you mean I just sang a
whole song about it of course I'm with
you and I was just like that's awesome
they're joking about it they're they're
acknowledging the kind of stupidity of
the fact that a random person would bust
out in the song and dance you guys are
so talented check it out
fart soon
the biggest event in Hollywood history
also it's just so great to see these
characters that I've loved ever since I
was a kid back and they're all the same
that all the classic ways you remember
them are there and preserved it's very
funny it's just a clever film the whole
family can enjoy with a lot of really
nice moments and some seriously good and
clever humor I'm gonna shoot straight
you guys aren't famous anymore yeesh I
wish you'd shot a little more curvy
let's just start at the bottom and work
our way back up to the top things that
did not work in the movie from me was I
felt it was too long and I felt towards
the end it got way too pull at the
heartstrings you know I just got really
touchy-feely every other scene was like
I believe in you moment you know what I
mean and after a while I was like okay
let's move on from this and get back to
the humor there's this movie in 3d no
The Muppets are is one dimensional as
they've always been
for the most part I've really enjoyed
the Muppets and I really think it's a
clever family film and it's something
that the whole family can enjoy and it's
just really nice that they're not going
for all the gimmicks of today and
everything and they're just presenting a
nice film that everyone can enjoy how
we're used to seeing it you know what I
mean no CGI real Muppet puppets and not
in 3d it's just nice it will write to me
the good old days so I'm gonna give the
Muppets a B+ whoa whoa
now if you guys have not heard of the
you reviewers awards the second annual
awards show is coming up very soon I
made a video about it earlier today I'm
posting that annotation here also in the
description check that out because
there's some info in there you should
know also check out their smells most
recent podcast with a lot of info about
that with Jeremy Jones Katherine Raymond
and Kristian harloff joining in as well
as Mark Ellis if you guys watch that
video and check it out and let me know
what you think of the upcoming your
reviewers ORS because it's going to be a
lot of fun get the word out that that's
coming out soon it's going to be awesome
look forward to that if you like my
review you can subscribe to my channel
and get stuck my dies